so each week I'm gonna talk about my
favorite Quito food this week we have
sir Kensington okay right here
mayonnaise amazing if you take a look at
all the mayonnaise out there every
single one of them has soy oil which is
GML let's take a look at the ingredients
we have sunflower oil egg yolks water
organic lemon juice distilled vinegar
salt Fairtrade organic sugar cane let me
explain you take a look at the
carbohydrates and the sugars they're
both zero so how could I have sugar yet
these be zero simply because it's less
than one gram okay that's how they get
away with it I will be talking to the
company to see if they could take the
sugar out that's the only thing I don't
like about it but it's very very small
amounts mustard flour black pepper
citric acid and it's non-gmo this one is
classic and then they have a Chipotle
one right here and they also have
mustard okay so I put these on my
burgers this one has water distilled
vinegar mustard seeds salt fair trade or
organic sugar cane again it's less than
one gram turmeric paprika clos cinnamon
and allspice can't beat that and of
course it's non-gmo and gluten free of
course there's no grains in there so of
course it's going to be gluten free and
fYI I have no affiliation
with this company I just think it's a
great company and I will be contacting
them to get this sugar out and then this
product will be the icing on the cake
I'm sorry not that's gonna kick you know
I mean if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos